[Applaudissements]
j'avais mis ma gabardine mon melon et
mes potines pouriner chez les parents de
Marie glantine tout en grimpant
l'escalier j'avais le cœur tout chaliré
et je crois bien que j'avais plutôt
mauvaise m cétait en
914 la vie s'ouvrait devant moi je
m'adais plidé ma cause en me répétant
tout bas pour vu mon Dieu pour vu mon
Dieu pour vu que je plaise à son papa il
na pas très bon car a a il se mène et
souvent t col a a m'avait dit ma Marie
est clantine il m'a pas dit quand
j'étais camine un paquet et dans chaque
main aïe aïe Aï je me disais pour vu que
sa maman aime bien les tulipes de
Hollande et les trucs au
Chocola c'est qu'en 1918 que j'aiépousé
la petite non par un Catrice mais pour
des raisons étrangères et lorsqu'en
juillet 19 n B un bébé tout neuf et
glantine me dit il tremblera comme son
père lorsque fermé 940 l'avenir
resplendira il s'en ira faire sa demande
en se
Réant pour vu mon Dieu pour vu mon Dieu
pour vu que je plaise à son papa il n
pas mon
cur il se mène et souvent en col lui
dira sa marie cartine en prenant un
petit air de victime mais pour lui le
temps des tiill durera bien moins que
pour moi en 40 on sera loin de la Guer
et ritette à ton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papa